I have a friend his name is Matthew  Matthew Osland  it's Australia and one time when I first  met him in San Francisco he taught me  something really profound and  interesting he said I like to go so far  away from home that the trees look  different and Here I am in Park via  Borghese in Italia in Italy and look at  these trees they are so much different  than the trees in San Francisco then  these mass of redwoods that we have in  California they're beautiful trees that  go up their trunks go up and then they  sprout out at the top like that it's  beautiful and I think that that phrase  could not be any more true today in the  world we need it today more than ever go  somewhere so far away from home that the  trees look different